bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono fa vj oggi
andiamo avanti con mesbah darracq
eravamo rimasti che nell'ultimo episodio
avevamo trovato st bambina che non si sa
come mai non ha gli occhi c'è guardate
che roba mi fa abbastanza senso se devo
essere sincero però va bene non posso
vedere non posso vedere niente
quell'uomo mi ha portato via gli occhi
che schifo e vabbè allora ragazzi io
voglio fare una precisazione
stiamo andando a salvare il padre di
vista bambina qui che stacca gli occhi
alla gente perché c'è un perché in tutto
questo non lo so la bambina non ha gli
occhi e non so perché la porta non si
apre
in pratica ogni volta che stoppa un
episodio nei commenti nell'episodio
precedente mi dite che cosa devo fare
giusto la cosa dopo ogni volta perché
sono mimì incastro non so più come
andare avanti
e vabbè allora praticamente certo posto
che ancora non ho visto
ok del cervino che cazzo è chi cazzo è
quello guardate sotto choc ragazze o
morto in cantina
raga e c'è un morto ma non posso
raggiungerlo bene ok a perfetto ok
ragazzi sono qua praticamente dove
avevamo messo palla di neve che era
entrato ha fatto casino è il sangue che
era uscito era probabilmente di quel
tipo ii che non so chi sia ma non lo
voglio sapere vabbè usciamo e abbiamo
fatto c'è ancora il cane fantastico ci
sono ancora qui cose che girano ok vi
stuprano ok c'è un fatto perfetto via
via via zombie ovunque allora laga direi
di tornare indietro perché mi avevate
detto che è praticamente la tipa che non
mi ricordo come si chiama con quella
tipa l'assistente di mio padre aveva un
qualcosa e io tra l'altro mi che non ho
visto ovviamente adesso vado a vedere
e io tra l'altro mi ero dimenticato che
c'era st via di sotto che non ero ancora
andato a vederla c'è proprio non sapevo
neanche che cazzo cioè non ci sono mai
entrato qui dentro cos'è un giorno sto
pensando le bottiglie e un problema
ok
strani strumenti per esperimenti
perfetto deve essere l'anticamera del
laboratorio di mio padre è bene che c'è
un secchio ho preso un secchio ho preso
un secchio lo so ma che cazzo è staro
odio ma che schifo
ma veramente dei bambini scatola questo
faceva mio padre non è una bella cosa ma
che schifo mio zio è si fa abbastanza
schifo lo penso anch'io dai bambini
sotto vuoto è caduto è caduto un bambino
è caduto un bambino a una bottiglietta
con due occhi è caduta con due o non
saranno mica gli occhi della bambina non
saranno mica quelli vero perfetto
raccolto la bottiglietta degli occhi
raga dobbiamo riportare gli occhi alla
bambina così se li rimette che schifo
raga sto puntata sarà veramente oscena
sta succedendo di tutto sono passati due
minuti cazzo va bene ho trovato due
occhi perfetto allora direi di tornare
dalla bambina ma prima mi avete eletto
di controllare la tipa che dovrebbe
avere qualcosa non so cosa c'è qualcosa
sotto la sua gonna ever vertità che non
sei altro vabbè che cos'è che c'è non a
chiave
non voglio sapere dove la teneva st
chiave sotto la gonna
va bene la prendiamo volentieri andiamo
via di qui ci avevo una chiave sotto
lago cos'è sta roba una una
c'è massima l'avevo lasciato anche una
gemma e non lo sapevo professor layton
non c'è più perfetto direi di andare
avanti tra la casa di cera sto corpo
prima ovvio che cazzo si alza piace la
tua testa qui è celato a te è il corpo è
qui c'è la tua testa tensione io me ne
vado di cose non mi stupra che cazzo
bene
ci sono corpi senza testa che stuprano
fantastico
oddio c'è uno zombie raga est a
buongiorno qui di passaggio vero ok
doveva ho soltanto chiesto buongiorno
era una persona sembrava così triste è
di certo in un posto del genere non è
che poi i salti di gioia ma non importa
io la seguì ray
se n'è andata no anzi facciamo così
migliorino andarci devo tornare davvero
prima raga non mi ricordo cosa devo fare
adesso devo mi ricordo cosa devo fare
ho trovato le palle devo dare le palle
degli occhi alla ragazza va bene lì c'è
c'è il maestro muten di di goku e vabbè
io di dragon ball non di cocco vabbè io
direi di andare avanti lo stesso perché
tanto ci ho parlato non dice niente
vabbè siamo tornati dove eravamo prima
fatemi salvare che non vorrei che mi
stuprate pure lei una volta che ci ha
gli occhi di acea gli occhi come ti
serve come faccio teli lancio alla
fessura poi li prendi li trovi si
ritirano non vedi quello ha preso i miei
occhi e io ciglio agli occhi sta
cercando negli occhi si sta cercando
degli occhi meglio essi brava nella
fessura o degli occhi qui sia anche a
voi capita ogni tanto di girare ad avere
degli occhi in tasca ft sono questi si
sono quelli di sicuro cazzo cioè degli
occhi di chi vuoi che non è che qualcuno
si è perso degli occhi ultimamente non
penso che lei possa sentire pure gli
hanno tagliato anche le orecchie è
chiusa dall'interno dai africa non è che
puoi stare senza occhi ho capito
vabbè a ho trovato la chiave anche ho
trovato la chiave non è che funziona la
chiave un secchio non penso che serva e
vabbè torniamo indietro raga sta
diventando quanta il cane se n'è andato
il clan e se n'è andato
non è una bella cosa che il cane se ne
sia in tanto qualche rigo non è che c'è
la nutella
è completamente divorato sì mi fa
piacere andiamo via
beh allora italia o cazzo stanno
distruggendo quanti sono prima erano in
quattro adesso sono in 200 ragazzi un pò
un casino passare senza essere mangiati
vivi
va beh direi di aspettate un attimo ok
vai bastardi come faccio a passare mi
sento che vai così ma è così vorrei che
c'è qualcosa sotto il tappeto tipo
novero no vai dai sono uscito e cambia
raga è cambiato tutto è cambiata ogni
cosa
buongiorno è quella di prima devo
seguirlo perché si la segua un bel
sorriso tra l'altro cioè fantastico e
devo andare di là la devo seguire si
possa entrare permesso un giorno ha tra
l'altro si sia adesso arrivo stia
tranquilla o anche la chiave se serve a
meno che non era più la porta a
buongiorno e fuori una bella giornata lo
so mi mi offre una tazza di tè è entrata
creda credo che voglia dirmi qualcosa
che voglio che stia tentando di dirmi
qualcosa ok ho una chiave perfetto
funziona ea non c'è nesso è nascosta
sotto il letto
attenzione che spunta buongiorno se mi
offre del tesoro sto cioè va bene cioè
non è che me la prendo
ho trovato un diario per raga un diario
potrebbe essere diario di maria
sinceramente non mi interessa però no
aspetta devo leggerlo leggi diario si
beh che è successo è diventato buio
cazzo leggi al bue dottore è passato un
anno da quando sono arrivata in questo
in questa casa e non dimenticherò mai
quel giorno perfetto fa piacere a è
morta è morta cioè praticamente la
trovata in mezzo alla strada che cazzo
per favore cibo si cibo non c'è nessuno
che pago chi cazzo stai parlando a
perfetto
qualcuno si è arrivato il dottore
qualcuno per favore sii dagli il cibo
perfetto
sì una vagabonda direi di sì non è che
una che trovi per strada e penso sia una
diva però vabbè
dovrebbe essere una borsa che cazzo
dovrebbe essere un soggetto perfetto per
per i miei esperimenti mica perfetto
raga è andata bene a questa e va bene è
andata un po me un po meno bene a quella
qui ha staccato gli occhi ma va bene
così pietoso vedere una ragazza così
magra
vieni a casa per favore sii ti darò dei
vestiti dei pasti deliziosi ok
e se l'è portata a casa e l'ha tradita
con la moglie resto è peggio di bio tv
il cazzo vabbè si si sta indossando di
brutto alla tenda teneva in gabbia
perfetto tra l'altro c'è anche il tipo
quello che sto seguendo prima non è lo
stesso il fantasma starei qui per un po
e parlerò la mia famiglia di the ok
famiglia si famiglia bambini moglie ho
una moglie e una bambina che sta
diventando c'è compirà sette anni presto
sono sicuro che ti daranno il benvenuto
famiglia da dire solo questo
vabbè ha tirato la testata la grata
tranquillamente va bene
sì ce lo zombie che si sta svegliando
buongiorno è una persona come me no è un
po più trascurata quella parte il fatto
che in mutande ma non importa che
ingiustizia deve far male si deve far
male
[Musica]
forse potrei fare qualcosa cosa puoi
fare poi prenderli delle bottiglie ok si
sta lamentando a me farebbe paura essere
richiuso con uno come quello è cosa sta
facendo la mia gonna non è abbastanza
lunga non ti preoccupare tanto le chiavi
ci stanno ma è l'unico vestito che ho e
questo va bene c'è andavo in giro solo
con la gonna vabbè adesso in mutande sta
diventando un orgia ragazzi c'era best
la stoffa bendando eh vabbè si è bene
il dottore entrato sono sorpreso stava
per morire ma ha recuperato le forze
durante la notte
[Musica]
sembra che abbia ricevuto un eccellente
trattamento ha forse per questo che l'ha
presa come assistente live curato sì che
brava sì se tale data eccezioni cache
traduzione di merda
hai un talento eccezionale ecco a me per
favore io non vorrei che tutto questo
talento andasse perso
qual è il tuo nome ma il nome nome di
battesimo
io sono io sono dai maria sessa fatta
maria maria un nome appropriato
non vorrei per dati per favore sei con
me anche perché ora sta messo questa
messa malissimo ma non importa è il
resto della vita è durata un anno poi
alla fine ma non ero così felice mica
sprizzava gioia ovunque così felice che
lui mi avesse salvata eros ora ma mi hai
dato quello di cui avevo bisogno
raga la webcam e crociata c'è nei primi
minuti di video voi non avete visto
nulla di quello che c'è
va beh come al solito i file vabbè porca
[ __ ] ma poi mai crociare mila webcam
durante i video c'è ma che cazzo va bene
mi porta scusatevi raga è andata così
vabbè comunque devo rifare tutto belle
ragazze ma va bene a non perdere tanto i
giochi come questi non è tanto
necessario a bene continuiamo mi hai
dato l'amore si va bene come potrei
vivere senza di te ti amo dottore ok
questa è una dichiarazione d'amore
fantastica mi fa piacere e direi di
proseguire allora ci abbiamo abbiamo
letto un diario a caso e non ho capito a
quest'ora diario proprio di maria e che
cosa cazzo mi serve non ho mai saputo
niente di maria dopo tutto doveva doveva
amare così tanto papa quindi ok a
perfetto e finita così
ok raga ma l'utilità di entrare qui
dentro in pratica quale era cioè non
l'ho capita perché qualcosa è cambiato
di sicuro ma non so il precisamente cosa
ah ok perfetto dove usare il vecchio
nell'acqua ci ho messo un'ora capirlo e
che cazzo me ne faccio li stosur ha lo
porto proprio così non lo posso rimette
allora che cosa me ne faccio
devo ammetterlo nel pozzo cosa devo fare
ragazzo suo secchione ho capito allora
c'è un secchio ha forse devo non lo so
devo spetta
forza capito devo spegnere forse il
fuoco credono roba legge si butta
l'acqua se ce l'ho fatta
ci deve essere qualcosa dentro fuoco
raga perché forse anche un passaggio
addirittura a puoi andare all'interno
del fuoco si perfetto c'è del camino non
del fuoco e zoom atto di bruco cos'è sta
roba passaggi segreti fantastichini che
alla cassa puntata epica a parte la
webcam
hai sentito una ragazza a stimare dal
dalla buca ok perfetto c'è una ragazza
di sotto
ho sentito qualcuno piangere questo buco
portano un posto sotterraneo kay
el'avevo dedotto anch'io non mi ci
butterei a pesce però se questa roba
cioè se questo passaggio ma nella
sostanza dovrei dare le do ridarle gli
occhi a questa è una ragazza di prima
perfetto ok
vai vai con gli occhi ce l'abbiamo fatta
la caduta ieri è ok metti te li paga la
cosa è oscena sto immaginando cosa sta
succedendo lì sotto
è una cosa veramente brutta però va beh
direi di tornare dalla ragazza che
finalmente agli occhi se lo sapevo
portava anche un po di attack e così a
meno stavano di più comunque va bene
abbiamo ridato gli occhi alla ragazza
quindi ci siamo fatte mi salvare è lì
che se li sta mettendo no li ha già
messi per questo brava a primi la porta
maledetta è chiusa dall'interno apri
stronza
ho trovato i miei occhi brava sim e che
schifo no non potete farvi vedere stesse
anche gli ammessi ai proprio usa e getta
una roba del genere proprio tipo lenti a
contatto si fantastico
qua siamo nel 2013 cazzo possiamo
mettere gli occhi toglierli posso vedere
bravissima e adesso possiamo andare via
di qui mandiamo in 76 tanto felice se mi
fa piacere per il compleanno ti regalo
una cover per gli occhi si è grazie non
ti preoccupare non è né a una gemma
tutto sto casino per una gemma ma che
cazzo e c'è un interruttore che anche
prima avevo visto che farà qualcosa
perché sono non so più che fare
si è aperta la porta fantastico
ok mi va bene anche così fatemi salvare
la gamba che non è da lì che cosa ci sia
dopo sta diventando quantistico c'è
veramente la trama epica st puntata
veramente se non fosse per la webcam
forse la migliore credo perché è
successo già di tutto andiamo di sotto
non sono scesa giù per le scale
eh sì siamo dov'eravamo prima a stiamo
scendendo le scale come anti chamber
cazzo stiamo scendendo le scale a
buongiorno non c'era prima lei si sta
divertendo lì dietro
posso dirmi alleano cazzo sempre un
rockettaro molto sciupato mi sta
osservando mentre vado avanti
si ok ho bisogno di passare di qua per
salvare mio padre per favore lasciamo
passare ok cosa potrei fare per convince
a testa lo fa amici cazzo mi sta
seguendo gli stop era visto plano totti
sta punta ok cosa devo fare devo andare
con lui io non mi sentirei tanto sicura
ad avere uno che mi sa che cosi ma
quanto cazzo sono lunghe scale porca
[ __ ] voglio vederti a risalirla eh va
beh noi andiamo avanti non è che devo
tornare indietro no infatti loro tornare
indietro che idiota perché mi stai
seguendo non lo so ma non dice niente
dopo una non ha gli occhi uno non ha la
lingua
cosa vuoi tornare a casa penso di sì c'è
anche perché non so che cazzo ci fa qua
dentro
vuoi andare fuori si può tardare dove
riempito secchio vieni qua tipo vieni
con me ti portano fuori poi mi lascerei
passare ok ok si perfetto vai non
ricordare dovrò prima
ragazze 1 che mi segue e che è successo
non posso andare da questa parte perché
che succede che cazzo succede non possa
andare di qua perché raga c'è qualcosa
dall'altra parte voglio vedere appena
c'è il prossimo quando torno indietro
faccio il giro voglio vedere che cosa
c'è
ci deve essere qualcosa di particolare
tipo che è successo se n'è andata come
se n'è andata e caduta in caduta no non
è caduta dove è sparita
che cazzo succede haga è tutto no sense
suo gioco cosa devo fare che è successo
a è tornata è tornata indietro cioè
nella stanza dei corpi è andata avanti
non indietro
questo è cosa io cosa sta facendo
che cosa sta succedendo a si ritrova a
solo io ma che cazzo sta succedendo mi
sono ritrovata sono io aia che sono non
ho capito che cosa sto comandando sto
comandando la tipa di prima
che cazzo oddio cos'è il padre con una
motosega aiuto
rimane ferma non lo farai papa
oh cazzo ha praticamente sta
impersonando la tipo di prima mi sta
facendo rivivere in prima persona quello
che è successo ok è così dovremmo
cominciare papà cosa stai facendo
oddio no che ski via via via via
lasciami avere con le mani bellissime oh
cazzo fermati papa sono io ok scappa
scappa scappa non posso parlare dello
credo stai vivendo in prima persona il
nuovo tipo di film in 4d o no quando lo
dico io cazzo stai ok perfetto c'è il
padre con la motosega impazzito
oddio cos'è sta roba mio più al peggio
dell'enigmista questo
sì che è brutto immagina stile scene la
dedizione
ok perfetto un flashback un flashback di
un altro per wow fantastico city o mal
di testa è successo
ok siamo di nuovo in piedi perfetto cosa
devo fare adesso deve uscire c'è sempre
il maestro muten cosa devo fare
adesso probabilmente vi lascerà passare
perché prima non sono passato credo o
devo andare di nuovo fuori non lo so
oddio non ci credo ma dai non si muove
grazie a cazzo vabbè schifo mio dio
perché io devo salvare mio padre perché
datevi un perché devo salvare mio padre
vabbè sono andato di sotto raga e sta
diventando veramente c'è un altro
maestro muten donda rivas un uomo
anziano mi sta puntando dirà
completamente fermo si lo vedo che è
fermo ma c'è un muro di qua a cazzo
posto trova sicuri cazzo peggio dei
fantasmi fatemi andare prima avanti noi
infatti copre facendo arrivare
va bene andiamo a destra andiamo in
mezzo ai numeri cosa devo fare qui è un
passaggio segreto hunt astico sono
adorando sto gioco raga epico e siamo in
un laboratorio un altro qua dentro c'è
una gemma tra l'altro sembra che non
vogliano presi facilmente tira una
testata delle tue cazzo ci sono delle
mani sul vetro sono apparse delle
impronte non lo so perché perfetto
infatti non lo leggere ho trovato
qualcosa qui dei conigli dei conigli
prima se prima c'erano i bambini
adesso i conigli ci sono ma che cazzo
questi conigli assomigliano tutti a
palla di neve è infatti li vedo che sono
tutti
non voglio guardare infatti neanch'io
gilet rientrare nella porta lega per
questa stanza o dio
cos'è sta roba e gollum come hai potuto
farmi questo non l'ho fatto io non ti
perdonerò mai
non l'ho fatto io non ti prende
incazzare con me senti un attimo vuoi
che ti liberi c'è tipo una corda di
sopra posso tagliarla o la motosega voi
cos'è
non si può tagliare come cazzola taglio
a perfetto vai sei libero ti ha aiutato
e non rompermi cazzo ok sta facendo
casini raga e ho liberato gollum e sta
facendo la guarda mi serve non posso
prenderla devo andare a grazie mi hai
rotto la teca sei un boss devono ho
preso una gemma perfetto ragazzi ho
liberato un tipo che andrà a fare un
casino infernale
direi di andare a vedere che bordello fa
ma no ha ucciso il vecchio manovali
poverino mi indicava solo la strada a
dei tagli su tutto il corpo ok è
spietato quell'acqua cos'è sta roba
ho trovato un cappello una notte sul sul
pavimento ok anno lo posso prendere devo
andare raga e ho paura di andar a vedere
che cosa ha fatto quel coso che non so
che cos'è c'è un'altra altra via di 4 al
3 ma perché tutto buio cazzo
e c'è dell'acqua nel vecchio che da
questo è un successo che tra che cosa ci
fa un allora in questi erano i
sotterranei di nostro padre mi spiegate
che cazzo ci fanno quattro cessi tutti
di pila
vabbè c'è una chiave nel cesso ma bene
prendiamo la tanto sto punto dopo quella
della gonna non mi stupisco più
dimenticate lo fa troppo schifo cosa
come puoi pensare che io faccia qualcosa
di così disgustoso non lo so magari
posso trovare qualcosa per prenderle ok
non lo so prendili guanti fa qualcosa
con la cole ciondolo no non so come
prendermi non essere così cattiva con me
stronza
io ti sto guidando ovunque e va bene ho
capito non lo vuoi prendere schizzinosa
va bene devi prendere le cose secchi o
no come fa dopo avere dei guanti raga
perché la ragazzina qui e schizzinosa
nolé prende va bene si in effetti non
metterà in anch'io le mani nel cesso
però vabbè non importa raga io direi di
salvare
sta diventando fantastico adesso io
dovrei andare a vedere che cosa ha fatto
quel quel tipo ii avrà fatto un casino
assurdo e inoltre dovrei andare a vedere
nella stanza dove prima c'era vino a
terra se si è alzato quel tipo quello
morto che c'era lì perché prima non c è
voluta entrare non so perché è un
mistero
io direi di concluderla qui raga come al
solito se vi dove è piaciuto lasciate un
commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come in ogni video trovate
nella descrizione se non siete rischi di
iscrivetevi e ci vediamo in un prossimo
video bella ragazzi